H
PTZLIERINZERI-WLANGNI P
YFE
ESNC.
WETE WANDO TRE PNTSE ONE OFUR O
ESGUTSOD TAYN I M THEEOR
IOADTRITCTL NALERME URFO.AT
AND WHO TSEHOAV HRD HEEAUR O
UEXTNE G.ST
THEIERN ONE OF OIS HAN MY TV
ARAPPEORCEANS TU LECSRE TTHA
C-
ASANSP HRO BCAADSTVE OR THE
SYEARIL WLW  KNO TATWH AATRE
'W'FO IREN
ANDHA TT GSTUEISS HRITOAN HW
BRDSUT ARHOF OUSHE T J
T
ASRELEK, BEDOO YHI WCH. SOUEE
INPEEKOVOUG T SH MERY .LDOUER
THOTZEE ALHEND A TIPMA ENCORAT
JORO BWNAMBR AAHCO LINLNND A
TH
GGSTE RU A FLEORNRIMECA
FRMDOENY AON W'H'ER OSBS
VE
ONETH CSIOVTRERESHI TST PAS
R
LOVER SCOINLN?TUTAES
ATTHEL CRAEBTE HISOL RENS A
ANCITOPARR ON SEE THE NEW AND
ENCURR TTVER SE S IETHORODGO L
I
.RD
ICWHH DZEMARATISOH JN ARO BWN A
OUZEAL OSFRE FIGOMED FERHTWS KNO
THS THI IS AIE PCEF ORYIS HTO
.
ATTHOU CLDOT NE  BURREMO CNTRE
LED ANRE
NTVA.
DAN PRO BSSFEOR HNDRASAS
ONRESPSDDE A AHE TY DAYLWSSOE
THWI AOO BKF O GATREHTNS IIGND A
HIGH DMARAK WORF O DPEE RHEAESRC
SODUN ASLYNASI AND GDOO
SHD-OLFANEIOD NVERAARTI
RAA
ANDTUOM MENNDM AEW FE EO PPL
DT
R.ET BTE
SO NOW TOSE U AROTEUO F
RSISBLHEY,EE WKLET LE M BNGRI
ON THE IFUIGNSHTLND A
ENNGAIRTNI BAC JK
NTLAON
RMCHAI T IANNHEN ITO HISRYT A
THENIVEITRSYF O AEX TAST
AU B HINWSOANRYT OVIL BL  TO
U.YO
ANTHKOU YAR HDOLOR FHA TTER VY
NTNDKI IIODUROCT ANNDHA TNKOU Y
TTOHELNIN LCO FUMOROR FHE T
OPYUNRTIT TORE ADDSS A YOUND
I'MSP EYIAECLLRA DWN TO THE
SPMRU AFTEC OHI T BSAUECSE IO
PEHOE WAN CAV H AEEL LIV
YCO
ERSAON TAROWD THEND E O
FY
SAN PELO I''ON GLA ENAXP
INH
Y W ITERO AOO BKBO AUTOH JN
BRNBRND A AINAMAH LLNCOND A
PAF OHE TRT SHO AWENSR I
T
C'LDOUN'TRI W ATE BKOOPL SIM
YB
RAT OUABNCM HALIN.OL
'I'SL WELWN KNO TO TUDSHI A
E
E THEROTEAR L ASNDOT LSF  O
S
T ABOUM RAABHAN.NCLIOL
SO IEE NDDEO TRI BNGOM SODEBY
IELSEONT THETO SRYHIND A TS
LYTUACALLE REFOMSCT SEF OY M
ENPEEXRI W ICENTIRING
BIS.PHRAIE
I'VEENRI WTT SEVAL BHIGRIOAP
N
D I DRECOISVE IDN WTIRING
RABIOGHAYPH TRYT TS ANE OIG M
T
BITHE Y RAOGPH HNNCAOTP.EL
BUTE GIV THESSMP IREHANIO TTIS H
OR HER SJECTS IENHE T C
F
UNTHE .ERIVSE
AND AS INTORMPTA ASNY A
DUDIINVIHT MALIGE BT THA
DUDIINVI N IALS T AOTTTE CHEEN
F
NIHE T U
RSVEE.
SO I WTEAND TO T SNGETOMHI
OUATTH WLDEN DECRTEEB SOMYOD
KELI LCOINLN ANDOO LK ATCO LIN
R
A PTHNOERTISPEREC.VE
TBU AOLSEA PRLLNIN LCO
IT WH
BOSOMEE. EDYLS
DANN JOHRO BWNAS W AREA
PONTCOEMFRYRA OLNIN LCO B,UTE
A
SLS AOER VYFU USEETOL  M
BEEUS ITE WANDO TOS PE A
QUOONTI TY MDE REARS A
ONESQUTI IHA TTOS PEDO T MY
ST
TSEN.
EAI TTCH A THERSNI UVEYITF O
TE
NDSXA A IAK ME ANT POIF O
TENTNGHI IORDUROCTSS CYLAESO T
TSUDSTEN WHORE A8 1 19 YRSEALD O
WHARO E ONHE TUS C OPFEC B
G
ZECITITH ONSF UB RISEPC.LI
DA' IT'S AST QUENIO WHA TTL.EL
I TUGHOHTF ITS A AESIM TELS
TIESON ANDT I ISER C
INTY
RTIMPORT ANFOENIT CIZ BIPSH,
UT
S GOEEY BDON TDS HIANHE T THE
ERHARDHE T QN STUEIOISHA WTOES
A ODGONER PSOO DE N  ITHFCEFA O
EV
WNOOU YAN CPRNT IERT TETHA
NA
YWAYT WOUAN THE WAY IHO CSE TO
TRPTERES IEL W ILN THEON CXTTE
OFIDHE T MCE9T 1H
URNTY.
ATWHS DOE ANER PSO CEDVIONNC O
THNERO WNGSSHE TL  EVIETH BAD
PO ACYECSPTS OF S?VELARY
WHS DOE TTHANER PSOOUO  DAB
TT
AT DO YOUO DF Y'O'RE
INCONV ADCES JNOHWN BROAS W AS
HAABRACO LMINLNAS WF IOU YR''
DINNVCEHA TT SVELARYS I.RO WNGO
HNJORO BWNOU WLD HAVSIMP EHADZE
ETHELVISP ATEC OFT A THEIN SLFU
PEASCTF O I
TBR A LAMAH CCOINLNDCEONDE
NO
TINTHG JONOHRO BWNN IIS H
ICCONVONTIHA TTRYLA SVEAS W
LONWRG WCOINLNLDOUND A DID
G ININTH OSPER ATSECS A WL.EL
IT'' BADIC POL
''ORAD B FHI WTEEEO PPLS A
LLWES ACK BLAPL PEO
'' BADOR ITEA THRNSTEHE T
OTUFURECRDEF MOY.AC
WR IITS G.ON
.SO
ETHST QUE INIOSHO TH.UG
WHAT DOOU Y DOUT ABO
IT?
ANDO ITE WAN TDOK LOOT A TWO
WOPPELEEE AHOGRT TDHAHI TS
THGAS W,RO WNG BUTOO TK
RIAMDIETLLCAYPP O VITOSEWSIE
WOUABTTHA TOO D AT.UTBO I
ANO S IOO LATK OH JRON B.WN
K  LIOOAH AATBRCO LAMIN.LN
ILIMPRARYHR TGHOU THEEN LS O
RTHEIUDTT AITESAR TOWDSRYLA SVE
ANDOR M IENTORMPTAIR TLYHE
ACWAS ONTOAVS RDSLY.ER
DANHE TYE WEROT BHOR BNN IHE T
RSFITAD DEC OEF THEH 19TEN CRYTU
DANHI TSS IOR IMPNTTA FORS THI
YSTORSEEC BAUME AATCARIN STUTIDE
SWATORD S.VELARY
W'REHANGURGIN DGINHI TSE. TIM
INK THIT' 'SAI F TRO SAY TTHAT A
THEIM T OEFHE TND FOU TG INOFSHI
ICPUREBL
1IN677RL NEAYDYRYVEBOHO W
THOUT GHABTHE T QNSTUEIO AT
ALL TUGHOHTT THALA SRYVE WAST A
NSTBE ARYESECSA
VI EL.
STALMOOB NYOD T ATTHA TEIM
UGFOHTLA SRYVE W AAS GDOOHI TNG
ROTHESHI TNGNG BEI.QU EAL
THHTHO TUGT IEL FL INHE T
GOCATERY OEC NSAESRYVI ELSE LIK
LI WAR IEA MNLM ATOSOD NOB
Y
KSTHIN WHA TTARS  I TGOA OD
.
BUT TN OIRHEAN HD,HE TN' AYR'T
RYVEY MANEEO PPLHO WAY SHE T
COUNIESIK LEHE TDNI UTETA SSTE
OUSHLDOR FWACERE WARND U AERNY
CICESTUMAN
ALT I FLS INHE TORAT CEGFY O
WE' DO'TIK L IETUT B SESETOMIM
IN WSHILDOROU YET GEDRA WPP UP
IN TSHI SFFTUND AUDTT AITES
RDWASLA SRYVEN IHE T77 10S0S 8
90EL FLAR LNLYGE IHI T
SCA
.GOTERY
AN SO YOU WLDIN FDEEO PPL
KELI TMAHOSRSEF JFEONE,EO GRG
WAGTINON WHO WEERLA SSVE
S,LDHOERUT BO ALSOS OPP TO
INERAVY IPRI PNC.LE
ANDMA THOSEF JRSFEONHOIS H WLE
RIFELI TOED TIG FEURUT OOW H TO
N
DRYLA SVE BAUECSEE H CEDCLONUD
THLAVE ISOT NOO GDOR FHE T
PUREICBLRYLA SVE
ISHI TS BADHI T?NG
RU CITORSPTLA SVE OERWNST A
TSRRCOUPHE TIRLD CHIN,RET I
UPCORROC DTSEMNDCYRA AT IIG MHT
RYEL WLRI BNGN DOWME 'CARI'S
RIEXPENNTME IGOEL SF-NTRNVEME
NON ABV OORUSIO ST OFNSES RPO
O
CEURNTY OIOBVUSNSES RPOEO T 2
.OMTHAS
JE ISOERNS
EL WL.
.OKAY
HESHI TNKRYLA SVE WS I
NGRO.
YWH D'O'T YOURT STAEEY  BFRGIN
LAURYO SS?VE
WE,LL IOU WLD POSEHE TUE QIOSTN
EEO PPLOD TAYPA COMBLRAY
IF
YOUNK THIAR WS I.RO WNG
WHY D'O'TIMOU Y ST Y PLNOGEWA
R?WA
BE TUSCAEAYODEEO PPL' CA'T
REGU OUTOR S OTFOW HO T DLEA
THWIIR THEOR W.LD
MOPL PSTEOEIT WUTHO WARHE T
E SEOMTTOM CMIEDAC PISIFTSUT OER
THE, BUTY' TH'RE VYER SLLMA
TYNOMIRI
AYYW.
SOH I AULHODDDND A T
S HIS
ALACTUCI CLYRU TALEIM THE
ONSIPOTIHA TTRSEF JFEK TONOO
THNGAS WHIOKN TOTO
THEY TUGHOHTT THARYLA SVE WAS
N
WITSAYUT OT THAT I WAS A DNGYI
IOITSTUT
ED LEYIV EON LG TUGNOHO SEE
THATLA SRYVE WAS BNGEIND E
N
NOTHE  SHERTRN
TETAS.
SO 1Y B080Y BEG BNIINNGF O THE
TH19TU CEN,RY THETH NORNER
STADES H ALLSI CON SEDGN
Y
TOHE TT PASTR O I WASN ITS W
U
THANT D IS B NOT
AUECSE
HENORTWEERRNS RE GBBRAED BY A
FI
T OF MY,ALORITUT BAUECSE
EEITHRESNOCOMIVOAD H EEDLV IN A
YWAHA TTREEN RDELAD SRYVE
ITPRUNOFNNLEAB URYESECSA
SDOF I YOUE HAV TORSHI STF O
O
OULRMAF N ARYESECSAVI EL, A
T
''ONO N LECRGE N,SAESRYHE TN
YO
F CUANNUSOC OVE EYNLLE SCA
.K
ET,AY L'' GETID R OFRYLA SVE
ANSOFFJEERUG TNHOHTHI WAS
N
GHTHOU TTLATHA SASRYVE W F
G
TIN SHEEAMAT COREGYN I THE
HAHUT WTHE TYOI DNG ANDHE TYO
THEDOT NICT THA S FVELARYOR
EXE.PL
,NO' 'MOR SRYT THACOOB TAC
IVCULTWHIOATN NHIC IOUHE T S
TA
BDOS NEVE SYLASND ALLCT AUA
A
E DSONYLAVES
IN
ECCONNASCUTIT
EL WL.
IT WASSTXH EAUGINS THIIL O AND
THIG FEDURHA TTKA OY,T' I
'S
TIMES  IMMONONE DAN
OO N
GHENOUEROU STHESSTN AT WLIL CEOM
HETO TUSON CCL TNIOTHAHE T
HENORTTE SRNTAS ARE AEALRDY
MICONGO TSLHA TT ISERAVY  ONTS I
WAUT OND AHE T SNTHOUER STETAS
LLWIHO CEOS TOND E SVELARY WTHA
JESOERN DN'I'SET ER O
GTSHWAIN DONN'I' MSET ETOS
PELE THEIM TE DN'I' WSET EAS
FI OF LHE TTINV IENFON O
THOT CNTOIN GND AEC SDLONYHE T
DANONHE T CTQUSEENRM ENOSOU
GR ITHN THEVAUL CTIONTIF O
ONCOTT WCHHIAD MELA SRYVEEA RYLL
PRITABLE IN THES TA STEERWHE
NE LULD ANCOD BEND FOUND AO S
SLPRYER SDEAND AT I HADS THI
RTSO O BWKFACLOLU INFCEENN O
PR
ILITOFABFYIT OLA SRYVE IN
LACPLESRGE IKVISOIAIN, ,
ERAVYAS W NEREV PARCULAYRLL
PR IABITLENNIIR VGI OANA DERTH
ESSTAT O TFHE E STEASRND.BOEAAR
I'LLEA LVEHE TID SE MOUBEAY STH
NAROCALIUT BN INIIR VGICH WA,HI
WA OIN KD TFHEEY KO T ALLHI TS
ERSLAV'WAY SN 'TLATIARCUYRL
PRABITLE ON ITSERWN O MNSIT I
VIYIAIN BHE TIN BEGNGNI OF
E
19TH C.TUENRY
WHSLAD ME ERAVY PBLFIROTAEN I
L
IKESAC LGI VEIRASANI WND A
ISTH ISOI GNGO TM SEE
CADORAXIBE MLAYAS WHE TND EGIN
HEOF TNANT IER SONTIALVELADE TRA
TOHE TNI UTADTE SSTE THENGUT CTI
OFMPF O ITSORSEEC BAUHA TT
ISRAEDALHE T V S OUEFVELAS IF
YOULO BCKMP ITSORND AHI TSNGOF D
THEAL VUES GOEUT OND AN THE
VIOUIAIN COR ELDXPTSLA SVEO T
EWETH NF GUL CSTOATE STAS AND
PLE, LESIK T
ASEX.
DAN SOHISE MAD SVELARYYEA RLL
ITPROFNDLEAB A W TTHAEASHI MNT
TSWAORTHA FPL PEOE LEIKL WEL
Y
THEIM TERSEF JFED, DONIEE H
RE
EDIZ.
OH I WAS ARO WNGUTBOS THIND A A
W GERATNIOF OTE STAANSM OF
PO
L TILICAS ADLEERLOMECA A.NG
E NCA WENAYPL HY  CRYLASWAHA TT
INY MANAY WSSHO TMA JONFEEFRS''
AIR.
WHEAS AEN KANCKTUYI
WASVE S ALAOL HRDEND AE HAS W
AALSOINGASTLA S
RYVE.
NDSO AOW NK BAC TOHA TT
QU
,TIESONHY 'ID DN'EFT J
RN
EJUSTATNCMAIPEDS?LA SVE
WHID 'Y CLAIPMA ENCEATIS H
SLY CESLA DIDNC EMA HATIPEIS
AAVSLESISERFT HTH DEAUT, B WHY
O
ITNIS HE LIFND AHE TNS ARWE
THEYOU WLDE HAVIV GEN WAS THA
IF
SHO TMA JONFEEFRSED FRESOU
IAVSLESFF  ICLNRHEY E  FAYRESHI
AVSLES TTHALD WOUAV HEEF AN CTFE
ONIVHE T LFES O TSEHOVE SLAS,
ISICWHH ALO  NSMG.THL IN
BUTT ILD WOUOS LEHE TMNY A
TIPOLILCAEV LAGEREHE TYAV HE
EROVADER PSU TGINIRHELO FELW
DEEHAVOL IRSNIR V ONIGIARN ISL
KE
TUCNTKYE FOREHE TIR SVELAS
BEE TYHE WLDOUPL SIMYAV HE
ACOBEMETHNOERLI ABOTONTIISUT B
FO AVE SLADE HOLRO T AUERG
NSAGAITIS HWN OAT MIAERL
IN
ARETESTNDAY S L'S END
ERAVYHA TTOU WLDIV GE TTHASL
PE
UCONRS M CMOH RELIDIREBI
TYAN
AYYW.
ISTHO  SBYHE T 10S83Y BHE T
S1830 ITEEC BAMLE CARHA TT
SLASYER WN I I FTORHE TG LON
HAND A ITSE CAU PDPLEOE WHO
UPREWE SSEPODO TLA SRY T
L
TOIN APL COUEF OFE DIFNTRE
S
ANDN I OP  CNEAMHNS WAJO.RO BWN
JOWN BHNROORAS W BN IEW N
D,GLENAN HUT BISAM FOVYIL M
O
IOOHHE WN HEAS W A YNGOU BOY A
E
RE GWNP U IHE T SNTHOUER PTAR
F
HI OOEA NREN KCKTUYLA SSVE
ENY,DA KCKTUYHE WRERYLA SVE HE
NTD HACOITTAC WHSLA SVE ON A
RGURELA PAS BIS WPLEOEHOWN O
ED
ESSLAV KN IYTUENCKOU WLDNG BRI
THSCR AOSOAHE T BRD PND A
E
INO OHI WOLDOU GNT IO KYTUENCK
AN L'EES SVE SLA
BOH JNWNRO S WASTOR OFD USE
TOSSHI A AID KTXC EEP HE
'DIDN 'TANERNDSTDTE QUIHA WTT I
UANMETNEILNT ONDAY D AE H
EDCARELLINHI TS ATIS H LE. LERIF
WHEAS NBO AUTIGEIN EHT ORIN NE
S YEARNDDOL AE HBEEM REMEDRE H
AYS WAPLGINNE OAY DIT WH A
PL
AMAAYTEHOOY B WNEAP HPE
O
BBE AOYCKLA B
DANN  JOH DOWBRNN'T R
LIE
ITHATTID D'N'IN SKN IT THAHI T
S
YBOAS W A S UVELANTILNT UIL
RAFTE TY'H'VEEE BNYI PLANG
THGEER EALENSSTILY AS EALQUS
ENTHS THI MHI WTEE CANAMNG ALO
ANRT STA YEDLIELNG AT TOYHE B
DANTI BEAR ONGVEHE TD, HEA Y
OU
, KNOWSTD ANJUNGBU ASI
IM H.
DANT IDAW DNEOHN O JN.BRN OW
WET W,AI A M
UTINE.
OK,AYO SS THI BOYCKLA B ISN I A
E
FE DRYIFOSNTRE P TIOITNNHA I
AU BAMECOD NSEOBLD CYOU DVE ERO
OATTH T ME AND GETY AWAIT WHT. I
SLVIOBOU
C GISUYIT DANO ISO  TTH
BL.OAKBRD
ANDO ST A TTHAOI PNT JNOHWN BRO
EDALREIZHE T'R' SSNGETOMHI
RENG WLYROSLIT WH
ERAVY.
BUTE HN' DID 'TWNOHA W TTO DO
TABOUT. I
DAN TSHIGAIN MS IYUN FALMEDANT
QUNCONTI OE A YOU
EEGR.
THAT S IVELARYS W
NGRO.
ATWHO DOU Y DO AUTBOT? I
HNJO DRO BWNN'I'NOT KWHA WTO T
DO
BO AUTLA SRYVEOR FEA Y.RS
WHEASAV HED KINF ODL MIL
YOP
TSEPODOVE SLARY ASAN MY
ERLEOP WDL MEILPPY OEDOSO TE
SL
ERAVY, I BUTTASN'TNT UIL IT
'SNWA'NTT U 1 TILHEHA0S83 TT
H
SIOPPOONTIO TRYLA SVEOR S OT
F
ANGALVNEDIZ I THEOR FMHA TTE MAD
MHIHE T JNOHWN BRO WHOEC BEAM
KNHI TNO ORYOW.
IEAV TO SAY SNGETOMHI
ER.
ANDT THA IS TTHAOH JNRO BWN
S
ANOT SSUC SCELFU
AM NE.
HEAS W NOTSSUC SCESLFU A A
.RMFAER
HEAS N SUCLSSCEFUS A A SEPHE
RDHEERR O AOW CR.ER HDE
HEAS NOTUC SLSSCEFU INRE THE
E
S''SSSIBUNEREEN VTURIHES  TED
N
' IDT'S A HTIOTYPHEUTLCA B I
IINTHKROS PBLBAY FRLAIY
RE TABONLEO SAYHA TTF IOH JN
NBROWEEAD H BNE MORCE SUC
FL
OMAT SHIETNG
LS EE.
HEIG MHTER NEVAV HE BOMECEHE T
ONPERS HHA TT KTOISRYNDWSNO A A
S
THISS IOT NSU UNUALPL PEOFTE O
I
IR TNDHENGAL CLIT SOR OF B
YTH
ESPRE OCLIOFS  EONNAMITI
TBUHE TCARI CTI MLENOMTN IOH J
R
N'O'UTEVS OL SN IOON.VELARY
ICAME.18N 37
ENWHHLI EJA LEJOVOY AND
NIITOLIOSTTO EDI WRASUR M
D
PBY AVE SROLA. MRYOB
AND
83 17.
ISTHS IEV SEAALER YO IRSNTHE T
BIH OF TL- FHEULEDROTHAT
ITABOLNIIOST MTEMOVENHEN I T
RTNOH.
E THERDHAEENL WELDAL CLE AN
PAANEMCITSONTIISAR EUAERLI QRSKE
FORMP EXALE IN 1 THE CH8TTUENRY
TANDREHEAD H BNEEEO PHOEPL W
T OUTHGHY AVSLERNG WISR'HA TT'S
VEDOTND E I BUT MYAN OF TMHE
HAN BDEEDU GRA.ISALTS
SOOR EMPXALE WNHEEW NOR YK
ENVE SDLA IRYT DIDO SN  IA
PHNE MEANR ANDS THIERAS W V
NDONMM A O ONEFHE TSO REANST IYO
SWAOM CN.MO
TSWATHAHE T PPLEOE WHOER WE
PAANEMCIHENGTI T SVELASAD H TO
GM
UN ATRO ADDA FUN PNTMEAL
AND S A ORCOUEFOS OPPIOITN TO
TH
IN EEND OGF SVELARYND A TTHA
ISVELASVE SLASER WE ABLAL VUA
O
PR ORMF .EROPTY
AND IFOM SE P HSOERNAD J
$STVEED I001,0LA AN SVEND AIN
THAS W TDOLHE TEX NT D.AY
,OHE' W 'REEIRENGOU YRVE SLA
.WE
T  TLLHA WRSPEONAVLDOU HEN A
ECOMICOM C LAIPLNTSIVEEA ADE
TH QOR MALN,STUEIOUT BRE THE
BEULWOD CON A EMINOCEN INC
S
WSAYITT AIW'WE, 'OTRE N
OG
O TO D
ATTH.
SOYP T TALICLYNC EHEMANATIPION I
TDEORRKOOS THIHA PM. FSEOR
SOFT AERAR0  1YES ANYER AFT 10
TARYESNHEVE SLA CNLDHIRE
HOW
MEBECOS?DU ALT
OK,Y THE WLIL BEED FRE AND
ANYOD BFTNOR AERINER CTAIM TE
I
F BLLEOERE S WEOU WLD GEIV
TOPPELE FE IMTOTHTOACR  IISN
ATHEONLIBOTIOOTIS TK
A
DITERFFENIE VW THELI ABOTONTIIS
O
TOKHEUDTT AIT
ATTH SVELARY IS SO.RO WNG
SOLVIT THAT  IE STMU B
DED
DIIMME
ELATY.
ANDEN ESSALTILYT ALL AOS CTS
W
WHATLLID D A ROS CTSMELLEAY ?AN
RFOY MANTIBO ALI WISONTSLIILAM
DLLOYSOAR GRI WNASRO P TBLBAYHE
BE KWNNOF OHE TLI PUB
INSG
ITABOLS.NIIOST
ITHANTEA TT OIOOSPPITTON
Y AVSLERDEEROVRO A ANENACTTHM
T
T IHEADE OFHE TUL RE OFAW L
IAWILLYD LMLOAR GFASORIN
Y
EDBURN AY COPF O THE
COONTUTITIGAY SINHI TS IHAS W
T
INK THIF O THEITON CSTIOUTN
BEEUS THEST CONNUTITIOSLL AOW
SLY.ER
SOBO AISTILION R TTSHELEA
HABORECO AISTILIONK TTSOOHE T
K  TIOOTIE THATHADETU TT
SIOPPOONTIO TRYLA SVEFIUS JTI
L
NYSTMO AINTHG B O FUTEWHEF TM
ILREWE WNGLIO TO G AS FARS A
JOWN BRO AND JOWN OHBR
WELMSFIL UASNWONGLI TO GS A
FA
R ASDI HE DNT UILVE E OSNTF
TH85 10S SCKHOEDIM H IO
ONACTI
E 10S85 T WASHE D
ADECE.
WHEN DSOE THEEEC DADF OTH TRU
FO THERI AMENCALIEP RUBCND A
FO DLIEANG WHIT THEUA DL
PRHAMSLE TTSI PERINEDST SCE
WR TG INOFST CHEONN.UTITIO
SOHE TST CONNUTITIO THE
TITINSTU N WONASOT REREVED IN
OSTHES DAYHE T WAY ITEN OFTS I
TO
YDAN I PTARSEEC BAU PPLEOE
LL SRETIGIV LIN WHOW KNE THEWE
OPPELEHO W WHETERO TNG THI AND
'IT'ARS HD TNK TOHIF O YROU
-DNEXTEIROO N ABOGHRS AODEM DIG
R
HIOM SETE LNGIK YHA TT,OU
AY, OWOK'HE TY'OLRE PNSICITIA
AN THE TIRINRYG TOVE SOL THE
MSOBPRLEHA TTHEYAN SVEOLUT B
TH WEEERWO TMEUN FDAALNT
S
WITHHE TST CONN UTITIOED ANON
WAOW HU O  DYO?UASQRE
THE EXIENCEF OSTA STE
HI WITAN
FERADELUB REPC.LI
ERWHEOE DSHE TAN BAL LCEIE
NTWBEEEUTHE T A ORIHOTYF THE
ESSTAT TND AHEHO AUT OTYRI
E
ONNATIER GALOV
ENNMT?
ANDHI TSNE OAS DATIBELERYEL
BDGFUED TYHENG FRASERF O THE
TUNSCOTIECONTI BSEAUY THENE KW
HEIF TD SYAI IKA OYFHE TY WTERO
DOW CVEN RY.ARLELY
THEER FED GALENEROVNMTLW ASAY
STAKE PNCCEREDEE ORVEHE T
.ATSTES
THMAHE T S SLL WTETASAVLDOU H
A
GE FIDOR
ITT .
'WE'OTRE NON G JNANOIS THI
BE UEUSERNDXIHE T EINSTG
MEVEGORNNT THEWO ART
RK
EDCONFN,ATERIOHE T STETASE WER
SO AIGREN A ANDND S TLLHE
S
EWERE
ALQU.
DANN IHI TS G NEWENEROVNM TTHE
BISTA STELD WOUE BOR ME EALQU
ANTH S THELLMATE STAS BYTU VIRE
OFARIRHE LEPRGE RATSERENTNIO
IN
HE TOU HSE R OFNTREEPSEIVATES
N
I ADNDELTHN E LTOECRA
COE.EG
SO IF TYHEAD HD SAIUI QTE
CLHEYRL TER FEDALOV GTNMEREN
IS SAYLWS.REUPME
THLD WOU'N'AV HEOT GNTE
ODYBYO T SNIG IF TYHE HADAN
SA
.ID
TOHHESTA STERE AAY ALW SS
E
WHENH PUS TOM CESVE SOHOHE TN I
T
ULWOE HDAVEE BNIM NO GOVPRIN
EROVHE T ATIRCCS A
EDCONFN.ATERIO
SOHE TYEF LS TTHI ONE
BEDELI VTERALYNDUEAG AHE T
LEPEOP WHORO WTE THE
COTITINSTUER UONND TOOSTD WTHAE
'DNDI'NST AHIRWE TSST QUEN.IO
WEJUIL WL E  HSTOPATTHHE WTHN E
QUASONTI HEO T B ADWENSRE
WERTHEELIL BEEO PPLERMA SRT
THRS U 'HE TY'LLE B IN A
TTISIONONS AR TH QUEIOSTNPO
ANE AY W WN'C'HEATT  TT.OM MEN
SORE THE''HA TTBL PROEMND AHE T
T
RORHE PEMBL ISHE TENXI ESTCE
OFVE SLA IRYN AEP RLIUBC A
RESICBL IICOL PITAL STEYSM
DBASEN OHE TIPRI PNCLE TTHA
PE
LEOPQURE A EALHO TSMA
SOFFJEER C ON,FRSOUE,T' 'S
STERED VYLYLE CAR ALL MEN ARE
DEACRTE EQU EAL WCTXALYE HAS W
TABOGIN A W AUTNDTHA HEAS W
TYITRNG SOAYN THEAS HEE BN T
O
CEUR OFAT DEBR EEVEIN SCEUT B
T
AS WER VYAR CLEN IHE TXTON CTE
OF ALIEP RUBNE OER PNENSO O
NDTEVO A ALL AHI TSHOINGA W
SVOTE ANDO S O'HA TT'ST' '
N
EISSUHA TTE' 'VELL AVE ORIM TE,
BU YHE WNOUAD H ALA CSSF O
PEVE SLELASHO WER WEO S
CLYRLQU UNEALO T EDYRYVEBO
EL
SEHE TNOU YER WE AFOINSKG
ANBLOUE N,AGD AI THERA FME ISRTR
H
ST CEONNUTITIO NHE TY WEER
NGASKI FORLERO TUBTXC EEPHA TT
THNEA RSO TTHA I EEDLAXPIN
IEEARL IRN78 1
EYRE PYTTUC MH ALL T
UGHT
STHAT WVELARYNA GASONIE D OF
ITEINOW WITTGH WNHI 1 O0R
S.YEAR
THLS AO KHAWNE T ITFHE TY
ILEELDTUT OCT EXA ILYNHE TSP
TUNSCOTI YONTI,W, KOUNOFF I I
THN'OU CL'T CEOM UPIT WH A
FU
HEEDG T-FHR TEETHS
SEROMPMIND ALL AHA TTTU SFF
HEENTH T TGE LHEARLA SINHOVELD
T
NESAT I THEOU S STHPLIMY
DNWOUL'' AIG SNNDHE TY 'LDOUN'T
TGET CSHIUTSTONITN.IO
SON I CHA TT AEASN IHE TAS CE
OFHE TALED FERNMOV GERRST ENVE
H
TE SETANMOV GERHETSEN TK KYIC
THAN COW DN THEOA R ADND
BALLCAYHE TYK TOOHE TOS P
N
LATIARCUYDTE BMIEN BJANNK FRANLI
ETHTH CLOESHA TT CUTSTONITN
CO ITIENONSHI TSITON CST
N
'ISN'ERT P BCTFE' IUTT'HES T
T
WEO AN C D TDEUNRHE
STRCCIUM
CEAN.
ETSO L'' IAK TE T OTUTREHE AND
LE THEEX NTEN GNATERIOHE T
ONRANETIFT AER TTHAIX F IT.GE
AYOK.
HELLWE T'R'S TSHIOU IHEND A TSE
PAOUF O I USEND A TY'H'
RE
INHANGR OGVE THERYOU CNT
NL
1THE A0S85NDT I BOMECESTT PRE
L
HAREA TDETHT E ES BTARON GNA
HAVE TOE BD. PAI
THLAETH F G AWSRENG TOAV HE
O
E BED REMYY BNE ONS MEANS MEA
OR STHNOERINKIO CKTHOFG F E
CADEDE WASHE T CISPROMOME O
CH W50HIUT OGERAD ESMELENTN O18
BOTHID SESF OAS MON-DONIXE LIN
THE STHOU WASLL REAY TPS UETTHA
CARNFOIA WASIT ADMDTES A A
FREE STETA TELSHI DERIVEDHE T
TESENANT IO THEAN HDS OFHE T
TAEEFR SS.TE
'EYTH I 'MNG GOTOIO TL CALHE TM
YACEXTL THELANT AISRYVEOR FSCE
ECABEUSVEOT N EBORYDYN IHE T
WRTNOHASAR PRLCUTILAY OOSPPED
TO
RYLA SVEND A US OYNL AMA SLL
NORIE MTYADT I AN OINRRVEIDG
BSUISE, TUTHETH NOR WAS A
ERDIFFEGTEN RNIOND APL PEO DEID
RINTHKLLIOEGNA T IYN DSEHOSAY
EV
ENHE W DTHN EYAY TOOD
'MORHUC MN TEHA TYHEO D.I'
TOY.DA
SO S THEOSTHOU LTR CTONOL
NTINCEEIV L ITVETOS E' IT'SO VET
IN S THEATENEEC BHESEAU TE WREER
MOOR NERTHNTE STASOW NE MOR
NO SRNHES.ATENOR
TH SWEE REN THOUERRSNASETO B
H
TH NEOR WASRA OUT BDGEAUECSE
ASHE TD QUIRO P QUOHA TT
THE
HSOUTTENS IIS ODN IT AAS WEW N
TIFUGIVE SVELANDCT A A IAWAT S
NEIVUG FITE SBAAYCKHATADE
MOSAEC NESRYN THAR EVE THE
WOF OPL PEOE LEIKETAR HRI
TU W OANF HJUE ST
RDEA.
BEUSCAET  I 1FOBERE085ORE
N TENHEUR FEWUT TEO SAYT I
TES WAOF
ICSUFFFNTIE IOM SNEEO ARE FET
EDFLVE SLA I,RYTAS W
FT OEN
ICSUFFIMNTIE SOYPL TRO CSS THE
ER RIOIVND A GETO INT A FERE
LATSTEEIKHI OOND AHE TN
OU Y
DCOULIN KD OFEL MT IONT THE
POTILAONHE TAY WDE FRECKRI
SSUGDOLATE MEL TIND TO
ONLAPUTIF OM, U PLPLAHIDEAHI
OTENWH GFRWA AY YL MOMARDAN AND
HETBU TIVUG FITEHE TIVUG FIT
CTEAV A TEA MNTOUTHA YOAD H TESL
TGE ALLHE T WAYO TAN CAAD
ECABEUS THEUG FIVITEVE SLACT A
IRREQU NEDNTHORERFFHE SRIS
EDGJUESNVERI PTEVAIV IND
S
TIFUGIVE SVELA ASND FORF O
ERHERTRN W WSHOOSEER P TEDO
SLY ERTO SAY IE HAV H TOPELN I
TH C OTUAPREF YOU JTUSS.LA SVE
THIS WAS ALE CARLA VIOFONTI O
EITHRSC CON
NCIEE.
THEYER W O.RAUTGE
SOEROR NTHNTH SOUOT BH T
UT
COTHE SEROMPMIF O IDHO SULAY S
ETHERER WE EAR LGESMELENT IN
NO AHNDTH SOUHA TTOW LT PAR O
H
EOM CEOMPRISF O85 1 A0NDHE TY
BEN TOOI PGE FNTINE MRSOR
SE
SLOUY.
NTHEYHEEREV T STH OERE.ID
ETHS-AN KSAKABRNEASCT AF O85 14
ETHOR WKRI PRIMALYIL OF
NS
CENT STEUGN VEDOSLAS THI IS
TONELUTHA BEHE TOP TS OFFHE T
HE
SAD OFY MANOR NRSERTHNE A
NDS
LYCIPEALPL PEOE OOSPPEO T
ERSLAV TYHE THE ORU CXFHE T
-NNSKAASARAEBSK WCT A TASO
ALREPEHA TT PTIORONF O THE
MIRIOUPR COMISOME0 182 TTHA
ARDHA BDRELA SRYVERO FM THE
HERTRN P TT AROFIS LHEOUNAIAO
SERCPUHA
ATTHAS W 18
20.
GOCATE ORYF WTHAURHE T JTHE
ISCA
ETEDLL SAWEDTL L
S''ROENBE ADUNOR F AON LG
E
ANDEROR NTHRSNEHO TSEEO PEPLHO W
AREOS OPPOED TRYLA SVE
.TH
EYRE PMESU TTHAHATAS W
E
ANPERMEATEN DNDL AHE TIRE HOP
WALL STI TTHA IF THEHRO GWTF O
SLYER CLDOU BEON C TINTAEDNHE
L
ERAVYNT EVE WLLUAYLDAL FL
IDEUNR W OTSWN BGHEIT,UTHE T
ASKANSSKEB-NRA S AACTSAYOR S
RE
R''GAK TINLIHA TT OFOFD F
SLY.ER
DANHI TSAS WPO COMDEUND TEEHR
SYEARAT LER WNHE THESRE DAD GOT
CASEROHE T GOTSTE GIOEC DIS
NSA
T. TIDHA
THSO MEIS CIURISPROMOMT TEHA
PA O TFHEISSOIURPR COM
E
HAD BNEENC UUTSTONITNAIOL
RM
BTHENGINEGNISEEC BAUT IER AFT
HEETH TSAN KSA NARAEBSK
CT .
IT WAS PESIOSBL FOREO PEPL LEIK
B
HARAMIN LLNCO WHONEET RURD TO
CSLIPOTIN ILL I LOIINSGEARLY
BEEUS OFANHE T KSSAEB NSKRAA
AC
ITSI PASOS FEBLORO IM H TY,SA
AYOK.
RECONGSSE MAD AAD BIS DECNIONI
RE TINALGNT HABALAN O SNRYVE I
THEROR NTHNAR PHEOFT  TRNES WTE
TESORITIE I BUTFESON CGRS
E
AECAD B D IIOISNN I85 14,T
D
KE AOO GDIOEC DIS INN85 16ND A
ORRESTHEE T B.AN
REETH DOTSAD GIS DEC SNIODAIO N
RENGSS C DNOANTTHO AT
THEO
SBASI OF THEAD DRESOT G DNISECIO
WA TTHASLA SVEER WEPE PROYRT
AN
JUD ST ASESON CGRD COS ULTNO
LLTE G AUYISN I MURSOIHO W
NTWAEDO TAK TE HSE HISOR
NTO
KAASNSND AAU BEC PSEIEPERORT
SPR
AEROPTY YNDOUAN CAK TEOU YR
EIVPRAT SRO CSSTETAIN L.ES
ITLD COU'N' AEL TLLA SERHOVELD
INISOISURHA TTE HOU CN'L'
S HKEIS AVELASOSCRSHE LESINTTA
ANTOIN KRRS SATE
ORITY.
WHATANHE T KBRS-SANEKAASCT AID D
ONHE TRO GDUNHHO TUGAS WVEO  TGI
BO?ID SES
OPRVE SLARYIS ANTVELARYND
OPYUNRTITO TIC BASLYALLE FX
THLEMUR SCAD ASHEF OOM SE STOR
OFARIL MITFL CYONECTIC BSEAU T
CIPRINEPLN OCH WHISAN KSASA KANE
ORRRTEITASY W ONPEO TEMET STLTEN
SWA WTHAVE STENOUGLAL CDLE
RPUPOLAEIOV SER ATYGNND IT
SO
DSUN IUSOCNNUON O ITS
AC.
'IT'S S AATMODECRCA AICS BEN O S
'
'VESTLETER ARO FMNYTA SNSTE I
ENI UON CAN GONT IOAN KSSA
ORRRTEIT AYNDHE TY CANAK TE
TH
OPR EIPRITTYER WHHE TM O
T
ERPROPPE HTYAP TNSO BE MESUL
D
ESHORSR OLA S SSVEOHE TY CAN
NMECO I TRO FMVE SHELA. OSUT
THOMAN C C IENRO FM THERE FE
NO
NDHRT AHE WNSAN KSARI TERRYTO
TSGE AUL POP LIOATNGEARNO EHUG
TOAR WNTRA AON CIOITSTUTNEST EAT
NSCOONTUTITISE THOEO PEPLN THE
DERESI K INTN TSAANSRYRIERTO
LLWIRITEON A CIOITSTUTNND AT A
ATTHOI PNTHE TL'Y'EEC DIDOR F
SLRYER OSTGA AINRYLA SVE
.IT
''OP U T TM.HE
ISTHS IEM A D PRAOCCY OPLEOEHTUG
GTOET THENMOV GERHETEN TT WYAN
OWH CLDOU AITUERG WHT. THA
,WELL F IN LTACCOINLN AUERGH WIT
IT BAUECSE ITRT OVE TNEURDSHI
PRSIBAC ECIINPLENF  OEVUN ATROD
O
R AG LONIM TEN JOHWN BRO
DEDECI TDORG AUE IT INTH ANO
ER
WAY.
NCSO OEHE TOO DRSF OS AN KSAREWE
HEENOP TNERET STLSAM CENT IO
ERASNS TTORIRYM FROHE TOU STHA
TANDYHEAD HVAN  AAD
AGNTE
USBECASA KEANUM ASSSSA KEDANS
RIT NTEXO TSO MISI.UR
RISSMIOU AAS WVE SLA S NTETAEDAK
CRORPO AE S OSTH
NELI.
TBUTL SETAMSER CE IN FMROHE T
NON JHOHRO BWNT AS THI PNTOI
IVSWA LGIN INTEPS UTAEW NOR Y
N
SDOE HEC DESIDO TO GO T
TNSKAASRYRIERTOLLCT AUAY
A
LECOUPF O HISEF BISEOR HDU A
LO
CE PNSREDEIM HNT IOSA KANS
ECABEUSY' TH'VE DIDECEDER HES I
THIM TE TE MOAK OURTA S
R
DOFREE T AMNDY'H'NA GREON BE
PA
ORTFT THARA MIGROONTI FM
E
HNORTO TET GO TSAN KSA ANDO T
TTSELE THERI TERNRYTO IAT GREER
SMBNUER THA TNHEERET STLROS F
MH
E.OU STH
SON WHEIMHE T TEOM CES TORI WTE
THE CUTSTONITRENIO FOMEDIL WL
WI AND TYHE LRI WTETEETRSE HOM
TOYND AAY SEA DRAT FRHEOM CE
ANTO KS.SA
THIS IS WREHE THEAT BETLVE OR
SL
ERAVY ISEI BNG. FUN
SO JOH BROWNSUAY SS' IRE'M
.MICONG
AND JNOH BWNROT SOR OF FNDOUIS H
GLLCAIN KN IBESAANS HEUSCAE
DI.EROVED
ATTHE HAD H AD KINF O PLSOERNA
MA
METGNISPL PEOE  WEERTOAWDRN
JO.RO BWN
AND TYHEE WERWN DRAO  THNJO
NBROWN I A WAYT THA SEOMTH OF
I
'D'ICPAT RT LARULLYEIK TYHE
RE DWNRA TOTOM CMIIO ACT ONSFWE
I
TENOLCEHETHA T AYOSLMT
YAIRTNL WEV NERAVLDOU H.DOE NE
THWITOUEAHE T LPRSDEHIF OOH J
NR
N.OW
T WSOHAID DN JOHRO BWN DOIR FST
OFLL A HEEDAT WCHHE WN T PHERO
SLMIY ERIM TANGRTSSA KO,AN
S.
THEYTU SFF BLOALTESOX ANDHE T
Y
ELTEECD AUS BOGTOER TRIALRI
ATGILESLISE URTHEDNN AOY
IM.
ANDAN BS OF PROLA SRYVE
CIMALIESSOU DNDCEEDN O THERE FE
E.STAT
THAT IS THEEROR NTHNIZOL CONED
UNCOMMFYIT ORE LAWE,NCSA KAN
Y  TDHELLSIBACARODEY STED YETHSN
TA
DAN THEEO PEPLIN LIV IGN
ENLAWRN' DCEI'TUT P UP AIG FHT
ANROHNJO B I WWNASDENNCSET A
TH
HISE HOU CLDDEDLARY DECI
RETWHHE HE WAS M IEORDENNCSE AT
PTHE'R'VE SSLA.RY
ALIMITIHE TO SDAL CLE THEOR BRDE
INCEEDNST AHE T THEIS ANTVELARY
ESFORCN INCAW LRE FEOR
NOT
DISTANFO UNGP SETHR EM
ESLV.
SO JNOHWN BROEDEC DID TO SDEN A
ESSMEAG TPRTHO E ERSLO AV.SIY DE
ONEAR DK.IG NHT
EDHE L ALL SMAAN BD OFIS H
OWFOLLNCSER IDILUNG AE OU CPL
I
.SOS NS
AND EYNDES DCEEDN O AMA S
LLA
ETML ONHE T BKSANF O
MIWATATOEK CRE IN KSAANS
TEORITY, ANDY THERA DEDGGE FIV
PROLAVERY SSTLETER MANM FRO
BEITHRSED B ANDY TARULLEDRDMUER
THAC PKM THEO TEA DTHIT WH
RDDSOAWO ASND LTEFORHE T CESPS
CE PINIEG LYS IN G TONHE
U.
THEPO PURSE O TSS HIWANDO  TSE
A
AGSSE.
TOER OTH WSHORE AINHI TNKGBO A
O
NGMIO TAN KORSSA FARIM SIL
ESRPPUOST  THAOUISTH CPE HLDAP
O
HE TM.
NOW 'M ALOAYLWS VEO TOR IMPT
O
THEAS PINTET RMFROGOLY
TE
ENPRES
L'I'US JTAY SHA TTF IS THI
EDPPHAEN WOD TAY BHOITUTGNKLIIN
ANYEPL PEO WELDOUIBES DCRE
JOWN BRO AS A TER
RIROST
USBECAS TEHIAS WN A ACT OF
TIPOLIIOLCA V DNCLEEEONO TEN S
A
ES MGESAON DE TOEEO PPLHE T
JOWN BROAD H NOCUAR PTIRLA
GR AEINGAST
IM H.
HTHEYN'A'EA TTHR JNETEDNOH
'WNDO'IFS L OER ANY LINTHGEIK
TH
.AT
S  TSOHIN  JISOH
OWBRN.
HE HASID DECEDHA TTVE SLA IRYS
SN
ELVIT THACA IT IFJUN ST
ERMURD
SO JNOHWN BRO DRSCOISVE
LLWE,HA TTOE D'S'T ECTXALYAV SE
TNSKAAS B THEHEGOTLATE
.
ANJOHNROWN WAS A LTLITEIT B
R
EDTRUSATSEEC BAUIDE H D'N'ET G
THIN KFD ONSES RPO
DAN WTE S IADULHOD THSOD MEGIN
REHE.
JOHN BWNROAM BECEME SUSFAI-MO
S
ESA RT ULOFS THI ANDE H WAS AOLS
NTWAED FORRUR MDEKA IN ASNS
TE
Y.ITRROR
SO YOUIG MHTNK THIJOHA TT
HNBR
E'NOW H 'SNGOIO TE BRRESD
TANDEDRIR OOM S LHIETNGEIK
ATTH.
IBUT TFAN CTSHIAS W IDATHN E
E
REFOGRHO PTOHYAPT A LSTEA
BEREVE CON PENNITAPTOHOGR
DO SHE TREER WEO NHO PHSGRTOAPYN
OF JNOH'RO BWNC'S INULRCAT
G.SO
HE T I ENDHO SDUL ADDHE TRE
WA
SO NER FEDAL LAWOR ENFMECENT
AG
CYEN.
NOINTHG LEIK THEBI FASO  TCH
EJO
BRO.
HESO TREE WERENRI WTT
PTSCDERINSIOF O JNOHWN BRO, BUT
THEDHE T FALERNMOV GER
TEN
USBECAET' 'SHE TED FS WOVHO GNER
NSKAASRI TER
RYTO.
THEYE HAVO TEL RY ON LOC LALAW
RCENFO TENEMT AONDREPPHEIM HND A
AL THESOC LALHE S AFFRIS
OURISAR PTSHEF O T CNTOURY HDVA
D
TO GO ONAS W AENRI WTT
RIDESCOFIOPTN BROH JN N.
OH ANDOH JWN BNROLD COURO G HW
A
IR OUTUT CIS HEA BRDND AIC V
E
AARSNG CNDHAEDAMIS H NEND A
SO
THEUL POPER VY IOATN.ND BLE I
E'THER 'SNGETOMHIE ELS GNGOI ON
E
,RE T.OO
TDANSTHA IT IET GSAC BK TO TSHI
ONESQUTIF O THES TA STE
RSS
NATHE  GONTIALENEROVNM
ERTHE WEER A LOTF O PPLEOEN
ETH NTHORLU INCNGDIOR NERTHN
FSERSHIFADHO W HYEA RLLTEES REN
H
E FHATAC TTHE TY W HADEER
GBEINREEQ RUI TDOWH DO Y TATHE
ERNSCOIDO TE  BETHIR DTYOR WKF O
THEVE SLASLDHOERHO W CLDOUER VY
LYEASIUR TNHE TND BLI T EYEO
BJOHNNDWNRO A
KA OY.
THEY JEA HRDNOHWN BRO'' INIR THE
CO.TY
LLWE TE'THA 'LL BEEB SOMYOD
'SEEL'ROS PFEMBL IE W JTUS LET
OMHI GSEEC BAUE' 'NG GSOIN I T
E
XT C
NTOUY.
SO J BNOHWNROCU CIRTELAD IN
HNORT AND HELAIR CCUDTENG AMO
TH
ELI ABOTONTIISNIOM CMUTY AS
FAAS ET ASNOS BTOND AOS MYTL
SWASI RAINGEY MON
HEAS WNGAI RSION MEY FISOR HEW N
PRTEC H ANDISEW NRO PCTJEAS W
ANKTT AACN OAR HR'P'S FER
'ERRP'ERS FIRRY VNIGIAN IHO THA
E
YSDAT WESNIIR VGI
HWHW Y IPEARRY VSERSEEC BAU
TH WEAS A FEREDAL AENRSAL
THNDE AN JOH 'WNRO'DES I WAAS
ZE STOEIHE T WPONS INHE T
NAARSEL ANDIS DEIBTRUTHE TM
GAMONVE SLAS INHE TITIC VINOFY
'RPHAER 'SNYER I THE SVELAS
UPSTGA AINHE TIR MTEASRSLI KILS
H
ASREI MRSTEF I NRYESECSAO T
E HIACEVFREITHR ANDOEEM D SO
SH
EAKHE TNS IONTUTITI SF O
Y
ATTHVE SLASLD WOUOS LE TIRHE
VA
NDELU AUAVE ENTHEYLL T
EHSLAV WDEOLRSLDOUE HAVO T
CO
EDNCE.
,OKAYE WAV HEO TE GIV UPS THI
INN.UTITIO
SO JS HIISENN OHBRR.NE
DANE' 'IN TSRYGO TRT STA
R
FRTWO  S TEEHE
VELAS.
ITUR TNSUT OO TE B A FSCIAOND A
I
OUTHT GTIETNGNT IOHE T
DETAS.
HES I CD.TUAPRE
'H'S AD ESRRTE'H'D TRS IE
S
EDHANG
AND INOI GNG TOHE T GEWSLO H
SL
UTSIP O ATOOT NE  HISRAI JLE
INE CHHI HSIOPPRHE.ED
ATTH THE ELSVIF OS THIOU CRYNT
LLWIPU BE NLEDRG OLOBYY  B.OD
LLWEHI TSEN STCK SHOVEWAS AS Y
U
NCANEMA IGIGHHR TOUHE TOU S,TH
YONO KW, HIS AACTTK WASN O
VI
IAIN.
WHEVI CASONEDCTF O TASREON
AGHETNS TNWOM CMO OLTEAHF
INRGIAELS A W ALSRUR MDEND AI
SO P WPLEOEHOER WEDKIE LLN I
IDE THRA
AND SO SNETHOUERAN BRSEGO
OINTHKOSMYH  G IH,FPL PEO LEEIK
HNJO BWNRO R ARENIUNNGRO AD.UN
WE ARE S NOT TE AFINON UHENI
.
SO THI ISSH OND A WHE TNR'E'
MA
IDET.OR WSE
WAHA TTPL PEOE IN THE N
TH?
OSTHE NNTHORERBO AISTILION?TS
EYTHLE HAIDN JOHWN BRO AS A
MA UYRNPOIS HTIXE ECU
AD
SWHENNETHOUER S ARSREFTOR O
TH
GE A.
OH MH, GYOSOT N OOYNL D WAVE HE
URISTH MNDRDE AE WAV HEPL PEOE
IN TTH NHEORHO WRE AINRA PISG
WHOANRE A CGIZONIN TSHI
ISRRTEORS TTSHIRUR MDE AND IT
OTSWA NUT OHNDLAISOR F
HESOUTTOERRNS  SHI TNKNTHOUER
SLRSOLEHDE TO IHI TNKFHE TY
RENEDIN IHE TON UNIIR FSTF
LALIR THETI INSTITUONF ORYLA SVE
WO BDEN IRDEO JPAYND A
IBPOSSIR TLYHEIVWN O LLD WESOU
BEPA JNEO T IRDFREREHE A MEOR
E
IKLEOP LE JOWN OHBR A WNHORE
INGETTS GGUN TO THELAHE T SSVE
OUOWH WL KLDIL TMHEN IHE TIR
DSBE.
SO IHI TSS S THEONUAITTIEN  ITH
SO
BU' IT'S NOT THEIR ENTE
SI
N.ATTUIO
INTACAH ABRCO LAMIN IS
WA
HITCNGLL AF OS THIND A HE
AKSHESIS HEA HD HEHU S WERTTSNHE
HE HRSEAF O JNOHRO BWNSEEC BAU
HAABRACO LMINKE LLNOO
ADT
ERSLAVY A SNDD,AIHI T ISS
.
THT  MISUSON UBEND
BUTUST I MET BON UNDE LY.FUAWLL
ITTUSE BEND UONND UERHE T
TUNSCOTIONTI L ACOINLN IS SAY
EDCONCEDNGOT NHIOHO T JNRO BWN
ISIN HFEL BIEHA TTVE SLARY WAS
EVUT, BLNIN LCOVEEL BIEHAD TT
N
HOHE T S RRTUNCT ANSIO OF
LOPPELEEIKOH JNRO BWNLD WOU
MAHE TTIIT SUA OONF S
VELS
E.WORS
IUL SHODNT POI OUTHA TT JNOH
'OWBRN'IDS RAARN O HERRSPE VY
D.FREE
NOGL SAINELA SS.VE
INT, FACOH JN BWNROAS WAR F LSES
SFCCSUESULHA TNETAR HRINUB TMA
INNGRE FEIS.LA SVE
ROHNJO BTS WWNANO TTA SRTHE T
HERWA TAR W'OE DSNS'T NDTAR A
FU
THERTRONHA N SVELAS TEAKP U
FFSHI O Y TEROOU KW,NO REISP U
AGTNS TASIRHE MRSTEAU BEC
SE
THEYEA RZELIS THIRO PABLBAY
LSOCOINLNHI TIRSNK FST OF ALL
PTHATLIPLEOE N JKEOH BRO BWNDAN
IO AINCTE LNSIKHE TAT R
ANED
ERHARP'' SER FRY IVELAS
TNE
TSHOR BUN R,Y' TUTHE 'RE FADOR
TH
ESSLE AVN IHE T LGUN ROO T
TH COU WLDOUSEAU SRSERTHNEO T
A
YCASILLO TO T CCLIREHE T
WANSND AO TIS RESTDENY A IA
GUY ANAR TNTMESTHAT I MHTIGE B
INIR THEWN O STEF-ELINNDSTRE A
Y.AVSLER
NO
THAS WLNIN LCOS''
HOHI TSHI T WSAS WTHA LCOINLN
LDHE OUTLNIN LCOIE BELDVET THA
YAVSLERLD WOUND EN WHEEROU STH
L
DEEHAVOLCL CRSONHAEDUD TTT I
OSWA N LGEONR INHE TIRNT IESERT
O
AIAI MNTVE SNLARYOW N Y,OU
TGHMITANNKHI MPL PYEOE AT THE
TIHTHO TUG
OY B, YW, KOUNOS THIS I A
G
SHOT BUT LINLNCOOU C PLDNTOI TO
THTA SSTE ONOTHF E HRT WHOT A
IMEON T HEADLL AEDOW SVELARY A
THEYHA C TEDNGIRHE MDSIN B
E
OLLINCBEDIN D EVLIE TTHA
IEONECOMER MSODZENIDND AHA W AT
EDEMORNNOCOMYDE NEEDAS W A
LEEXFLIBOR WORKFCEND ALA SRYVE
F NISOTEXILEBLT ALL A
.
I'ST JUS T OHEE.OSPPIT
WA ASONYS TY,HIS ICO LIN'L'S
BPEUT ITUT BT' 'ET SSOMNGHIHO
THE HBE TASO BEEVLIE
USCAE
OLLINCN PSUT.RE GAT
HEAS HER REFCEENOR FHE T
COONTUTITIND AE H KWNEHA TT
CETHUTSTONITUANIO GDNTRAEE
YAVSLERCO LIN'L'ER ISNTIOETPRAT
H
E CUTSTONIT0NIO 7RS YEA OF
0AHYE 7 YRSEA BYS  THIMETI OF
RPINTEONTARETIF OHE T
TITINSTU HONAD CEDCLONUDT THA
ETHTE STA CSLDOU SAV HEVELARY
S
NGLOS A TYHEAN WDTE LI'LNCO'S
ONSIPOTIALAS BICLYAS WESON CGRS
N'C'L TTELTAHE T SSTEHA TT TYHE
'CAN'AVT HELA SRYVE AT TNDHAF I
VIIAIN OFEO GIARG,OU STH
ILIRONAFSI MISIPSSPI WTSAN TO
HA SVELARYL TILOMIN KGDOM CE
THE S CTETASAVAN HERSLE AV
YUN
NGL TIKIMEM DOCO
ORIL UNTHE TON CIOITSTUTNS I
DEAMENDHA TT WASIN LLN'S
A
NOW.
HE 'LDOUN'TAV HE TO GET
Y IMANIT TONAMGVE SHELAUN
STUT,ES BE HOU WLDAV HEO T G
O
UPME S
RTPO.
TSOSHIHAS I WTCO LIN ILNS
FMIAING TO'REHE'STH ANOER
G
TABOU THASHI T L ICOINLNS
NGTRYIRE TO ISVEVI HICOL PIT
AA
ERRE.
DANE HANE H CTHEA RD
EDE
HIGRMOAP
ARCHNGGI TEA RDHESU CENSNSET RUR
AN HELI REAHASZE TTHE T
HMARITF ICET OECE THEL
RATOL
EGCOLL
ETPRTYH MUC GEERAUANTSHA TTF I
THISEW NICOL PIT PALTYAR THE
REICAN WHICH HE HASOI J
S
LLNTSEIA C AY MRTHAERBEEMR OF
RTHECAUBEPLINAR PTH ITYF
N
NANOMI.TE
AOD MATEREDI CAN
TEDA A
IDCANDE.AT
O'W'T? TSHA
WHSOTNOOE DS E SCT AR.OPPELE
TAND WYHELIL WIN TY'H'RE JTUS
TH
Y MATAN EOR MEALCTLEOR VESOT
IN THE NTHOR T ANDUB RHEEP
S
'DON'TAV HE T GOET ANY EALCTLEOR
VO FMROHE T S
THOU.
RTHECAUBEPLIIDCAN NDEAT'OE DS'T
THAVE A GOETES VNYOTTHRO FM
EO
H.UT
SOCO LIN ILNSRY TGINO TOR ST O
MPTA DNOW A IADEHA TT
BLREPU AANICSRE EREXT ASTMIS
NH
H HENERDEABO AUTHE TAI RDN O
SRPHAERER FRYND AS THIUY GOH JN
OWBRN,E' 'SEN OFTAL CD
YATAWOM ARO BWN BERFT A
.
IT WASOU FNTGH IAN KSSA
ORRRTEITRE WYHEAYE  HPL AED
NGARSTRI
OL RE.
THATRO BWN WAS N AOT RCAUBEPLI
N
T TDHA HECO LIN WLNAS N AOTN
IOOLABITNDSTNI AE H BLYICASAL
STPU A MHUCTA DISENC AS HEOU C
E
EETWNLFIM HSEOHND A JWN BNRO
ASORAY S F THEEA RNSOT THA HE
TOUTHGHHA TT'RO BW'S WSK ORWA
NOLYON M,ALORLY WLEL
LEPROBTIMAC TO PUTLDT  IMI
LYM.
GERRDINE EO PPLD CINOL B
THIS IS NOTET SOMHANGHI TT
WOLNCNLI WASILNG E TOORSELI
BU
TLS AASITO  WICOL PITLYAL
RPUNCOTEIVDUROCT
SOIN LLNCOT  SORREOF T TSADSHI
OWNARR
AT PH.
'HE'S AATOD MEREN O THE SJEUBCT
'HE'PPS OOEDOS TRYLA SVE
T WTHAHA TT FEA MNSCO LORINLN
ISLA SRYVE NHA SLLOTAN EXP
O
WETHE TEERSTN IEITRROR
SO HEAM CIGPANSINGASTPH STE
O
FLAUGSOR IS'INLLO'S SATENE
SEN  I
5818.
HEOS LES TTHACT ELEN.IO
HE RLLEA'ID DN' ETECXPTO TS WIN
LADOUG WSAS AO S THEIO LN OF T
E
BTENAUTHA WT LCOINLNID D WAS
TOAK ME A FAM NEOR H?SEIMLF
NA.ALONLY
HEAS WIN LLNCOAS WNI RUNNGOR F
ENESPRIDINT 85 18HE WNE HAS W
RUG FOTHE T.SE
ANACIND  FNAHIT S .ME
ADSPRE AUNRODHE TRYOU CNT AND H
E
SWAN SEEY B THE RCAUBEPLINS BY
RTE THSO PF OIOFEROSSLNA
ANBLPUICSBE TO HE T SEAF
EIDNDATOT GHE TATOM NINNIOCA
I
1860ND ALNIN LCOAS W TIG RHT
HT
ICHMITETROLE ECTGEOL CLE
HATTH'E'NA GONINND AE HID D
HE P TONHENCSIREDE
AND ATT THAOI PNTEL WL ATT THA
TPOIN PHE TTLOCK THIS,EN WENOW
RY SETO ANDO SCO LINLNET GS
ELS
ATEECDNDOU STH CAOLARIN
AAD PARSO OEF  SHEUTRNOUTETAS
F
NIHE T U.ON
AN YDOUNO K WW,T SEORF O WE
TH
K W KNOT WWHAOIAS W G
N
.HERE
DAN YND AOUW KNO FOR THEOS M
T
PARTHE TER GENALER PNPTCEIOS I
TD
T TUEHAHE T IOU STHSON C
OUABT THEUR FUTE OFVE SLARYND A
EFTHEROUEOR S SERTHNTETASEC DEID
TOEA LVE T ANDUE IHESSS I
Y.AVSLER
AND YH,EAHA T'T'AR PTTH OF
EST
TY ORBU STETAS LEIKOU STH
LICARO C HNAADEDTEONNDINEL WL
FAHE T NOMTHOR SEOR N
ERTN
ESSTAT ASEL WL AES TTIMNGOO LKI
A
TCKO
HA TT.
IDAL TKEUT ABOHE T TWOLA F
D
ETHITON CSTIOUTN, Y KOUW,NO
WH''HE THA W'T'HE T BYNDOUAR
NTWBEEEEDHE T FALERER GOVENNMT
AN STETA GENEROVNMND,TS AHI TS
A
THONS E AI RATEMD.NE
RCLUNEAND ASTA STEOU WER ALDSS
H
IGREI RSHTN I THEER FED
NTRNVEMETSS AER ITSS IG RHTDANO
OBDAN NADYOD HUPOM CE AIT WH
SO
ONTI.
ANDHE TREAS W AON STROO SGCH
F
SOUTRN TUGHOHT BUT I SULHOD
AD TTHAAN DEBLIE WANERST DLIE
WERTE SBESCUBRIO THI TS AT AN
SRLEAYGETASAR CREET THA THE
ESSTATAD HOR FD THE NLIOATNA
RNGOVENDNTME AFOHE TRE
TRE
ESSTAT OOU CLDPTF UT O OETH
ALTINAONNMOV GERT.EN
ANDO SVE ERYOU S SERTHNTETAHA T
T
DESECEDID SO CGIMLAINT THAT I
TSWAIRHEHT RIG ASTA A SDO TTEO
SO
DANOU STHINAR COLADA HUS JT
OUABTEF LTHE TON UNIN I83 13
A32ND3 183 ORVE AAX TUE ISS18
H
EY DN'I' ALIT KEUEEV REN
ATA
FFRI.
HEDAN TCCY AIMLAED THEHT RIGO T
DO SOND A SHEO TT LYEFHE T
N
ONHE TSS IUE OFTA S'T'HT RSIG
O
TWHE'TA STE 'S
HTIG.
ATTH OAS W GFTATREESOR IMPNCTAE
M TTOHES A MFTOS O THE
DINAFESNC OSIEC SESON
IN
D.CADITE
IT WASLA SRYVE, BUTHE T'R'S
SO
GTHMEIN WRDEI AUTBOS THI
BEEE USTHDERE PSI ONTF
THE
EDUNIT STETAS HAST JUS BNEE
ATEECDND WTHAE' 'SIN SAYG,S I
ATTHTH SOUAR CINOLA,IR VNIGIA,
YO
CUANP KEERYLA SVES AG LONS A
NTU YOWAONHE T CIOITSTUT
ESANARTET IEL WL,VE LEA THEU
UNTHANN D ST CEONNUTITIO OF
UTHETENIDTE STA D'SNOE'T
TEARGUANE YOUINNY ATH AG. ATLL
ANF IOU YT JUSHI TNK AHEUTBO T
A
GSTHY IND UR TNET.OU
IFVE SLASLDHOER IN TOU STH
EDWANTO T PESERERVLA SNDRYVE A
STHEY FEDECEDT  TORHAE.RPPUOS
EYTHUR SEID D ABLER TRI JEOB
ECABEUSNIT WHIWO TEA YRSF O
SE TIOSSNWOND A AAL HFEA Y
RF
SIEC SESVE SONLA WRYAS ONTS I
A
OYUT AND BY 1586 WT IASON GE
F
HE TTH SOUATN ERST AEST THE
SLTE SESTANOHAS D DESET CE
D.
TH CEYLDOUE HAVAD H SVELARY
LUNTI87 100 188 MNT UILELBEAY W
A
CALL WHEY TNHEDAN WTEO T
GIVET IP. U
ASOWANYY,IN LASLNCO HECO T DEID
TWHATBODOO  ATH SUTOUNER
IOCESESS
ANDE HAK MESER VYAR CLEHA TT
SO
ILHUT WL B NOTWEALE LOTOD
D.CCSUEE
TBU AOLS MESAK VYERLE CAR TTHA
SHIPL COMITNTAI W S THHETHOU H
NOINTHGO TO D AUTBOLA S
RYV.
ITAS HVE EGTHRYIN TOO DIT WH
STES RHTIGS INAR PR.CUTILA
HE RECEJTSHE TOU S
ERTHN
ENCONTHAONTI T S TTHETETAS HEAV
TRIA GH TOEA LDHE TNI UONO S
NNCLIOLAK MES VYLE CAR
HAT
THIS WARS IBOOT N AUT S.VELARY
AS H TOAK MS  TEHIINPOT
BEIREUS F OSTF, ALLE' 'SD SAI
ALLO ANGHA TTHE TALED FER
NTRNVEMEOE D'S'E  HTAVLNTCORO
OVRYLA SVEN I S THEANTETAS
DH
S SEUN KTITAONLAPSEE SSSVE A
LOEYS  ATH
AN WT.
TBUON SECOTYDL N A NS IOT
L
SLTHE TAESAV SCCS TESU
DEE.
AND MDYLARANID DOT NEDUC SCEND A
KEKYUC, MISOISURAREL DAWE DID
NOTEEC SEDNDF I LCOINLN
EDCLDEARNAR W OVE SLA,RY TNHEE H
DWOUL AECFFT BE DNGLAECRIAR W O
ETHOSOR BRDES,TA STEHI WCHE WERN
ABTELULY CCIRUAL STRALEGATIC
O
HE TRE PIORVSEATNUNN IO I
HLARYNDTE SADEADHE TN
THE
EDUNITSTA STENMOV GER WTENLDOU
VEHAAD H TCU EOVAASEAT WNNGHITO
ANOUT I WLD BEN OHE TUN R
.SO
INCO HASYO  TSAT THAS THI
IWARUT ASBOSTA STESIG RHT IS
AB W TTHE BAYUT THE WARS I
AB
HETOU T.NI UON
HE DTETAS'O'E HTAV THE
IT
TO LNDVEEA A MHAEOR TN A
EAR
IN W TTOHEAR ORS  IY EEGRLEETH
IOOLABITDISTNI ER.TO
UYO KWNO ID SAI MR.LNIN LCO Y,
N
Y,OWOUOOT G T RLIEAZEHA TT
THEAS I RYLL HISAR WAU C
Y
ERSLAVMAANY D AI IKE SL, WD,EL
HEOOERNDSTS TDHILAVE WAS
AT THEOT BMTOF OS THI PLATIARCU
I
UTSPE, BCO LUTINLNAI SDHA TT
KYOU TWNOSHI MY WAR N IS
OTABF
LATOU SAIRYVE S K YD,OU
ULI COD M ATY VOCEOI TAVEHE
IEND IF CLDOU SEAVHE TON UNI B
R
AINEEG TLLHELA SS.VE
T DIO ITHAF I CLDOUE SAV T
HE.
BITYE FRE OON NE TFHE S
OI D TTHA IF I CLDOU SHEEAV T
UN
YNIO BNGRE FEI OAL HF TFMHE
IO DT. THAHETHAL HF ANDGEON BDA
MY I JOBAVTOS  SUNTHE E .IT
EVLYTUENAL ELLNTVEUACO LYINLN
SWAER PADSUEDSAHA TT HENGVI T
UNIRREN QU.ED
BREG INTH SVELASR O ATST LEA
FRGINHE T SVELASE F  OTH
L
E SLAVS.LDHOER
ECABEUSENIS H GALERSOI PEDNT O
N
DPL PEOE LEDE FRECKRI
DOSSLADRG AUEER VYON STRYGL
LAATTH SVEAB LORAS W AOR MAJAR W
CESOREURE F  OTH
UTSOH.
TTAKET.HA
SOREWACEUR AY ALLSERO PMI
DOEEMO THE TVE SLAS ANDIC ENT
O
HEUTRN SVELASO T TLE FE
HE
TAPLAN AONTISOMND COE T THE
UN SIDND A T ALLDE SHEUD
HAGSIN T YTOUHA CENG
THETH
NCBALAEO SLNIN LCOSSS IUEHE T
EM
TICIANPACL PONRON,ATAMIOUT B
HEMM ILYIAEDTED, SAIOU YW, KNO
ITHISTO AS SHAAPPG W WTED NEE
TOO IS TOME ANDHE T
TUNSCOTIOONTI SLNIN LCO,OU Y
AOWSHE T STOR OFHE TT LASCT A
OFISE. LIF
HEID DT'N'EALREIZASHE T L
SVITISTIF LE, BUT HEET GHE TC
13THME A TMENDNTOUHRGHON CESGRS
ANT' 'SYAI FRL SOTMOH S
LG
TOICAT RIF
IOATN.
S' I'M GNAONTO SRE TPHEEC BSEAU
'I' FTIS MEST QORUE
NSIO.
WE,LLHA TNKOU YL. BIL
THONAS W W.RFDEUL
TH WAS A WULDEONRF
AL TK.
OTWE G A LOTF ORE GATST QUENSIO
THAT CEAM IN D YINURGROU
S.MARERK
AN F THESTIRNE O HAS TO D WHIT
HNJO'RO BW'SIL FAM
WERE TREHEGTR SONLANT AISRYVE
ENNTSEIMMOTS ANGER OTHRSEM MBE
OFIS HYAM FILNSOR F IHINCTAE
SA
ERTH.
JOHNWN BRO''Y.AM FIL
JO WRO BWNASUI QTE AYAM FIL
MA
HE HAD 2DRCH0 ILTW BENY S.WIO VE
ANCHTHD E DRILENHE THE T
ENILCHDR DHE TYN'I'EQUT ITNOW
TATOE MAK OFIR THER.AT FHE
THEY ALLRE GW UPEDPP OOS TO
SLYERIV GEN J BNO'WNRO'S
ULWEPORFNAER PSO
TYLI.
OUIT CDL HLDARBEY ER OTHSEWIND A
OF CRSOUEHE TY LEDIV IN AN
IOOLABITOMSTNI C WNIMUTYREHE
ISTHS IT WHAY THERD HEAND A
NINBEGNETHORERF,RS OE,OU CRS
THN
EYAD HO NER MATLIAESNT IER
ERSLAV
IT WH KHA TTDINF OCA EDUONTI
OUEYTH W ALDLLE BPP OEDOSO T
SLY,ERUT BE SOMER WE MEOR
DPOOPSEO TRYLA SVEHA TN O
.
ESO HAD H I' CA'TEM REM
RBE
TLEXACY HOWAN MYE MALLD CHINRE
TBUOT NLL A OF TM JOEDIM H
LLSIBACA OYNHE TEFAT BTL
NT.
SOHE T BLD OERDS OYDIE H HAD A
ERUGDAHT IEVAD H SALERGH DAURSTE
ANDNE OF OIS HTEAU DGHRSAR MEDRI
A GUY WHOAS WTI INILYALIN KD O
A
YNKE B JNOH BWNRO ANDDOI JNE
JO
WN BHNRON ISA KANS,UT TNHE
HIENWH TINSOS N-EEAW-L SS THE
THLENG W TSOOHCHHI JNRO BWNS I
GGOIN TOO. G
HE BLYICASAL SSAYKA O ENOH.
AYHE S ISOT GOO T GAC BK AND
TTENDFA MOY LYMIND AGO HE
ES
TBACKOEW NK YORIT WHHE T
NDTEEDYAM FILAS WIN LIV AGND
OEHE D'S'T CEOM BAC JOHWN BNRO
HORPLESIMMEO  TCO
AC BK.
O,SO N' 'M NOTGOM CINK BACNY A
HEAD MEP U EUSXCES THE JNOH
BR'N'S SONAD H A RLLEAY STOR
OFALMB AIVELTEN RHIIOATNSH WPIT
H
REIHE FAT
EYOU CN'L'ID DTECTH WEHEER HE
WASHE TOS MTMP IESSREIVNER PSO
TH TYHEAD HR EVEET M ORHI TS
NDKI OFTI EMO MALONLY
ALORY
IVABUSE
ON S.
OONEF HIS S SONDAIHA TT H
REIR,AT FHE SM, UTOR OFOO LDKETH
KELI AIR BDF PYND A HE
THHATGH TS TTHI OIR BDY PFRE
NA GSON DOM CENDNOW AET G TMHEWA
IFHE T'ID DN' DTOHA WTE HDAN WTE
EMTH.O  TDO
SOUTER INTLYTIESNGAVEOH JN
BR WNASY VER TDEENROW TDARHE T
YORGEHI CRELDNHE TLD OERHE T
BOEC E,SP ELLIAYNGECXPTIO T
PKETA UANRM AS  HJOD INIS
ERSLAVY, AYRM TUT BNG YHEOUER
CH
HDRILEN T WEASDEENRDOW TAR
EDAN H WAS ASDE TEN ARS BOU CLD
O
ISRDWA H.IV WES
EVENEL WL, I''OT N'HE TRES NO
RACONTNCTDIIO BER HE,UTY THE
TWERES OHENEPE SALCILY HIS
SEE WNDIFHO WAD HO TD TENHE T
EAMEHOST
LLWE, HEAS W O Y,FFOUNO KW
NGWAGIAR WSTGA AINLA SRYVE AND
HIAM FYILT AOM HEIV LED ON THE
KISSNEBOF O AISTILION
TST
S.NGRAER
SO WHE TREAS ASC SUBNPTRIIO
NKEP UO T SPOUPRT JNOHRO B'W'
A
OLYMI SE HOU CLDO G OFFND A
WA HISIG FHTND AHE T'R' ASN
INN
INRETESTGICYN DAMHA TTOE GS
ONAMGHE T TLA PHEHIISHRNTOPCTI
IOOLABITFSTNI IANNE O W TTSOE B
AEIT LTL L BIT CSESBLRIHATAENE O
DCOULAY SHE TCH ARMRAI
ABSTIOITNIHO WRE A FDIUNNG
HNJORO BWNSEEC BAU HE IEDREMPSS
NOEMTH EYOURMSLEC BSEAUE HAD H
THOU CGERAF O TIRHE
COS.TIICON
HELDOU AYUACTLL W DOTHAY THE
TNTWAEDOO. D
TYBMAE TUGHOHTUGYHE OHTO DO
CBU'LDOUN'RIT BMS TNGHETOVEELS
DO
DANT' 'STAMP IOR.NT
I TNKHIHA TTHE TYNE KW THE
ST OSIEFHI TS GUY WHOAD H
COMUTEITD N,ERRD IS.AN KSA
TBUTYHE CUOSPONICLYUSNEEC DLI
O
SK AN JOHRO B.WN
DDI YOUO DT THATA CAPINRO B?
THSLW AAYDAL CLEID DOU Y
DO
?THAT
T'ID DN'K?T AS
EDAN H MEAD AOI PNTF OOT N
NGSAYIO SE HAD HS THI AIR OF
ERMYSTYUN AROD HIMNDHE TYL WEL
FHETAC WN WNHE JNOHWN BRO W
S
EDREARST ATR'AR HP'SRY FERND A
OH ANDE SOM OFIS HNAER PSOL
SISSPOESERSON WEZE SEID ANDT I
WA
LI PSUBHAEDSH T HTE HAD A
OFNCBUH RSET LTE
ATTHAD H BNEEEN TAK SO ESTHE
HOLEOP W HADEE BNTI WRI HNGIME
ERLETT
D FEYLEOUHE T CNDRYNT AOTE W G
TO GETUT O OF HEERAU BECSEE W
MITE BOU REDNDP UND ALE HAUD
TO
NIIR VGI AANDED TRIOR F
SOEAN AINGASTNIIR VGIAO TTR
T.RIGH
HO HBO AUTIS P?ENARTS
DO WEW KNO HOWIS HAREN
GHTHOUT ABT OUY?AVSLER
ARAS FS A IAN CEL TISTSAR PEN
WEOS OPPEDO TRYLA SVE, BUT
TH
EY WEERF O ANLD OER GEREN
N
EWHERSSHE T I S OUEFVELARY
SEED TO BEUC MHES L ISTEEDMMIA
ANHAND A TT STORF O THE SRYTO
OF JNRO BWNND A ANDHY WHE T
I5018SHIS TE TSIMN WHE
EVHIYTNG CESOM T AOEA HD
BE IEUSTKS LOOIK L FE AALINLY
E
ISICIONNA GSONE HAVBE TO
MASHI TNGRE AOI GNGN IHE T
WR DIRTIONN O S FVELARYMRO
ETHNT POI V OFWIE THEHE T
NTPOOPNE S OSFVELARYN IHE T
S
OFOH JN 'RO'ARS PTSENVE SLA,RY
HEETH T GERENALSSS IUE
IK LE
GSTHINTOEE SM E B GNGTH IN
EI
RET GHDI
IOCTN.
SOHE T IRE'S' TTTHAH MUCNO KWN
HIOUABT NTPAS RENDBES YO
H.
.OKAY
WNO ONE OF MYAV FITORE
HIICORAL DTAUMOCENSESRI IHE T
AMXPANIC EEIEERNCNE O AUTBO
ROHNJO BWNNEND A OF OUR O O
F
ETHUE ISSS INHA TM FTILAS HO T
ITDO WTH WHHEERR OEOT N HAS W
AAZCRY WNDE GOT Q ANSTUEIORO F
M
LMEOO MCH WREHISASK AS YS Y
OUE
WN BLLROLO Z AEA ITNHE T
OFR YOU BK.OO
E DDI H ACOBEMEN?AD MMA
IF BYAD MNMA SYEBOMOD MT TNSHA
HET LOSOU TH WCHITEA RTYLIND A
HE 'LDOUN' TTLEL WHA WT
AS
ALACTUOILY G ONGN THE.OR WLD
HEOU CN'L'TL TELEA RTYLIRO FM
MASHI IONNAGITI
N J,OHRO BWNEV NEREL FL IONT
ATATTH CNOOREGY  BJOW HN
WN.
DIDL FALNT IOAL CTL A TNC TRA
OF THESO PERREWHN O IZALES H'E'E
GOE TOG  BYRMAA RT
ANDHI TSS I SNGETOMHII'HA TT'M
RELY IEDRINTGUHE WN I TRYO T
TGEENS IIDOH J'N'D'RO GU'SD HEA
AN IAN CEA RDIS HET L FRSTEMRO
ILJA IN WNTES IGI VIRANIND AOU Y
CA RDIS HTE STA ANTMESND
TSMMCOENEOF O PHOEPL WAL TKO T
HI TT AE. THEIM
THES CEOM AOI PNTHE WNN JOH
BRREENN TEERHAD RPS''
RR.
HEAS W FLYUL CEDVIONNCHA TT HE
WAE MOR VEUAALBL TO F THE
M
MOMEVENTVE ALIN THA
EA DD.
BUTENET BWEHE T TEIMHA T HTE IS
URCAPT AEDNDHE TE TIME HS I
EDECEXUT
ZEEA RLIDT THAE' ' OSFRE GERAT
VAELU T TOHEOV MENEMTEA DD
N
E.ALIV
AN SOKEE  HMA CVES RYAR.
ATTHE HL WIL NOT CANNTOUENCEOR N
ERCOOPEATIT WHNY ATFF EORO T
EEFRIM H JRO FMNDLAI AOM SE OF
TH WOPPELEHO HADE ROD WIMHIT H
INS.AN KSA
WER''HI TINNKGUSER SIO
OLYF
G GOINTOPE HARRY FRSER
CHNSTLEOW WASRE WHE HEAS W
JAPRND A S AGIINNG YNDOU KW,NO
EYTHHTHO TUGL WELOW HAR H CDAN
THE? B
'I'SUS J ATRYOU CNT
AI JL.
ACIN F W IT,TAVLDOU HE BNEE
HETPRTYECDAR BHESEAU TER GOVRNO
OFGI VIRNDANI A THE TN
HE
RNGOVENTMEF OHE T UNITADTE SSTE
JURO SUR TDEUNDHECE PLAH WIT
A LIMITIEND ANEV FALTULY
EL
IESOLD.RS
BUT HN' DEI'T WTANINNY ATHGF O
ITEC BSEAUE HEA RZELIDT THAEL W
E
OIAS W GHI TNGO MAKE
AND HEAS WOI GNG TO HISAK MER
SU
INERG.
AWHATDUNMOTE TO INIS H MDIN
MA
M YRRTDOR TH JUSECAT US
ANDND AS THI WASHI T WSAST WHA
SOOV MEDPL PEOEIK LERY HEN
THUEAND APH RAL WDOALME EONRS
H
ATHI TS GUYOU WLDIV GEIS H
ORFELI F AAU CT TSEHAT AST LEA
SO. FAR
EYTH HAD OYNLEE BNRI WNGTIOR F
AN
AK SDPEORGIN F SS TOHI WHE T
OFWEPOR BROH JN N'O'
PLEXAME ANDT' 'S YOUNO KW, I
'S
OWA P SFUERLNTTETAME Y,OUW, KNO
Y'AN C' MTEAK AOR MEER POWLFU
ENATSTEMN TTHA AHA TT,S THI I
F
EOU CRSHE TSO REAN TTHAOH JN
BR
NOWAS HON RES TEDATOUGHT
HIWNY ORDONOIL TL
AHYE, INK THIF O THE LEIN FRO
TH
VI MEELELLOE PMHE T PTEORNT
THAL CLS HIMRET MEOF OAR W
D
ATTH UONNIOL S GERDISO MGCHARIN
OFIGO T FHT TOUNHE T TE OF JNOH
'OWBRN'S
OD BY.
'THATSNPI INSNGRIG SON FOR
TH
IF YOUT WAN TO ASKELOU YRSF,
H
WATASOH JNRO B'W'
SCOORSTY?
TIRINTBUHI TONO
UYOAV HE TE B PDPARERE
TO
ASWANEROL CORRYLA QN,STUEIOUT B
CETHRYOLORLAST QUENIO IS
AALTULY BQUGEIGR  TTIESONNHA
ROHNJO B.WN
OUDO Y?HI TNK
THATHEIV CILAR WR O SNGETOMHI
VEUC MHIK LET I WES NASECRYSA
TOND ELA SN RYVE IERE THAMANIC
UTSOH.
DANF I YROU AWENSRS I YHE,ES TN
MLIKEEVIELL'OU Y'AYD SN JOH
NBROWS I THEET M TREOTHALSIG SNA
THARHE T WS I TBO AUTO.TA SRT
'I'S YOUNO KW,HE TNGPE ONIHO ST
OFHE TIV CIL WARUT BN I IFOU Y
ELIBEEV THA TT YNHEOUL WILAY S
KAATTH OY,OH JN BWNRO WASIM SYPL
GINJOINATHE T BETLHE AAD OF
N
THE B FTLATEYMAORLLTA SNDEDRT A
YO 'REPPNAON AOHUDLA J BN
,
KYOU SWNODIOLEROE GS HIV GES
I
.FE
ON THETH OERD HAN IFOU Y
HK
INAS LHOLNCO THTUGHA TT A WAR
WA
NSOTEC N.SAESRY
TH T YOUEAK ARAT RHEFE DIFNTRE
VIEWF O JNOHRO BWN BAUECSEOH JN
BRNAS W C AOOD-OLBLDDE
ERMURD AERNDE HAS WNEOM SEOHO W
TR TDO ATA SRTAR WVA PRI
TEC.
AZETINS TRI TEDT STO AR
AND IFN JOH'RO BW'S AIOCTNS
CO
TERINTBU TDOHA TTAR WN THE
THE'DDS ALIOITNA TLO BODTHA
BHNJOWNRO HASN OIS H HDSAN
LIIMNOL H
LFSE.
DNCOUL'' DUI QTE IIDECE SAY
BE
REFO THE WARLNIN LCOAS W
CENVCOINT TDHALAVE WOU
D
OUWITHR.A T WA
BY THEND EF O THE I WARN
N'NCLIOL 'S IONECDALUGNAUR
S.DRADES
HE 'S AKIALNGUTBO HOWT IAY ME B
'GOD'LLS WIT THA EVE DROP OF
BLN DRD AW S TBYHELAVELAS ?SH
LSHAL BD PEAIOR FH WIT D APRO
F
DBLOO BRA DWN TYHEWO SRD
N'NCLIOL 'S TINAKGIT PHEOSNIO
EDAN H STF O ERO FMALTIMOON
PE
IVPERSCT
YRE PTT HUC MHAS TO TEAK TSHI
TIPOSI.ON
ISHEOTRW MEY, GOD KOU YW,NO' 'M
BLONSPSIEOR MHAE TN A
BOY
ELSE FORHE T DTHEASUNF O HEDS
F
ANHO TUSDSF OEO PEPLND A
DYBOLD COUR BEAT THAIN LLNCO
BEH  MMEUC RREMOUSIGELIO
AINCLED LTE STEA H ALKTASNDLYIN
ANTHKS AOT LOR MEUT ABOIOEL RIGN
TRIDUNG. WHEAR
IT 'S AOSLMTUG TSHOHE H H NASO
,OICHCEUT B I''US JT GNAONUT P
ON
TENGHI T TOHETE LISRSNEND A
S ATTH IATTH SVELARY V WASYER
ONCOMM IN THELD WOR IN80 1
LLNTSEIARY EYVENT COURY IN TES
RLWODLL AEDOWRYLA SVE IN0 180
N
.1900
AL NSTOOU CRINTESN I THELD WOR
ALLADWE S
RYVE.
E THERCOE ARA ROLEUP AD.UN
BUITT AS WNL OYN IHE TDNI UTE
ESSTATHA TT TIN EHENDGF O
RERAVYDUIEQRE GHI TSATRESL
WVICIL.AR
HAV MO TEAK ITTI PAR
AL
PTEXCENIO FORAI HTI
HI WCH
ALACTURT SLYTAOL REDEV AIOUTN
BIERAR ELI THA TNUTT,HA BOU Y
GE
TTHE P
NTOI.
,YEAHO ND A SERTHE'OE DS'TM SEE
O
AE BGTHNYINN IOR ST OF THE
YSTHIORHEF O TLD WORF ORE FOMED
OFVO E AINLVGESITTTUD SHA TTSAY
YO TVEHAOAV HAE IL CIV W TARO
O
I
SDOF I THE CILIV WAR CLDOU
N BVEEEEDVO AID TNHE AS I SAYHA
UTIT PN JSOHRO BWN A
ER VY
ERDIFFGHT ENLI
T.
'THA'S.RE GAT
UME' 'OT GNTE A LOTF O
ONESQUTIUT ASBOTH EANAW HKEND A
OOETH GD BOR LDDIR. NOW
I'AV HEN 'TNEEHE T FAVMIL HEOU Y
DANF I YOUAV HE COU Y SAKPEO T
ITHOW TSEP DIC
IM H?
IAV HEEEOT N SARITN  PYTL
BEEUS 'ON D'TAV HE SEWTHOIM
BUTO ALSSEEC BAU IE MAK A PNTOI
OF NOTIX MGINFI MY WIIOCTN
Y
.FACT
AND WNHEM I ARI WNGTIUT ABO A
ECSUBJ ITID AVO R ADIEANG
FI
L IOCTNATSCOACUNHEF O T
SUOT,EC S IN' DI'TEA RD THE
MCMEJAS  BIDBREKOOOOHE T GDD LOR
BI
IE SEERBA ISS NDSE O WNHE IT
CA
OMEUTSERE PCIAU BLYECSENO A
A
IDBRES AD GOO AANHOUTR  H CAN
ASPIN CINVIONNCRY SGTOND A I
USDUL JTGI IMANEHA TT ILD WOUCO
READOM S AHIETNGUTBON JOHWN BRO
INNDREHE AOUT I WLDTI SCK
NI
EAMY H I ADND WHILDOU TNK OH, I
E
HAAD TINT E SOMAPIO BGR OHYF
JO.RO BWN
SO IAK ME AOI PNTF OOT NNG DOI
IST' I'VEEA RDEV RWSIEND A I
GAER TOHTHA JN BWNROPP ARSEA
ONHE STOIEERS O T HEAVNE OR O
TWO S
EWCRS.
MILYLD L
SEOO.
HEE H 'SNOE'TM SEEIK LE SEONE
O ISS ILL AHE TGARE A,IN IET G
ISTHNL OYRO FM R,IEEVWS
UT B
'THAT 'ST'H' I ASLLAN CAY S
HETOU TTIEP DICUT,ON B W ILIL
ATITREERT WEHA IAI SDOR BEFE
ATTHOH JNROWNER CINTALYOU CLD
LLTE RLIEATYM FROLL I
IOUS.
FSO IDYNY ABO AAK MES,LA CI' I'M
TNOGAY SIN TTHAHE T SIEERSOE DS
OHETH JNRO BWNROWNHIAS W T
N,Y AZMAI HE TN INTHK IUL SHOSCR
DAD THELIEP RUB LNSCABREIK AAMAH
N.NCLIOL
TH TER WEHE F TSTIROAY SN JOH
NBROW WASS AZY CRABEAN M,
E
THEYN' DI'T WTAN TOE B BMELAD
OHRFO JNWN BRO THELIEP RUBNSCA
LIADNOL HLERO TUB A.EALRDY
HEASAY ALWS CLEALD ACK BLA
BLREPUNDANIC ALA BCKUB REPCALIN
E
DECFLTEOT BIR THHELA BCK
HE
SCTSAR ABEDO TSEHE
ICPUREBLNDSAN AACHE T FTHT AT
THEE SMO THEE B TAVY F
EDOR
TSRIGH TOR FHE BEOCKLA PEPL
N
ICAMER
Y SDO,OUNO KW LCOINLNLD WOU
NOTYWO  GANREHE NREA AN
ABSTIOITNINY ALI ABOT,ONTIIS
BU
T A LETNYNELO AIOLE
ITABOL.NIIOST
YE,AH IHI TNK OFLNIN LCO INHE T
O
EROPNI UONSSDD ARE HHE WRE'E'
D
NGESDRSIEROU STH ARSNE HNDE
SA YO RY T TKEMA US O
O
OHBE JN'BRN OW
'S.
'ATTH'S N WOTHOE WRE A AS A
PA
Y.RT
ANGHRIT' IDT'UTS BLS AOHE T'R'S
GA IATRENYRO
ER HE.
ANDT THAS IHE TOH JN BRIWNRO T
S
STORTTA A WARO TRE FES THI
SL
NDESAV A F
LSAI.
OEHE D'S'T STT ARRY WTOORID D'N'
FRNY A SVELASLNIN LCOES TRIO T
DAVOI WHE TAR ANDHENE HOE DS
GO
ORO T WDSOT NREO T FS TEHI
SLOES T S TAY UHEUTONNI B
N'NCLIOL 'SSAR IHE TH MUCRIG BGE
WAR IND ATOE D ESNDY B F
EG
THEVE SLA
FRE THE''SO L AESNE, HER
IT 'SHE H ITOISRYL FSULF O
EEENS ANDT WHA YOUTA SRTS IIR
NO
SSNET CEWHILARY U E ERYODEN
.UP
AHYE,HA T'T'IG RHT AND YOUW KNO
ECCONN TD TETONETHA ONG THI
IT JUS T OUGHOHTF WNHEIN LLNCO
SMEETIT WHRIRE FDEOUCK DINASGLS
.
NCAOU YK TALBO AUT TTHA FOR A
COSENDR O NOOR F MYIT LARERY
PUFESOS IRIRE FDEGL DCKOUS
E NDOT.STXIED
AHYE,SEEC BAU IEL TLHE TIT
LLPARA I AELNDINERNTTWGIN
SORSTIEOHF O JWN BNROND A
MRAABHALNIN LCO T B,UT
THO
R NEVET.ME
ANDO S IDEE NDEEB SOMOTYOD N
HOLYON W M HADETH BOTHO WLD WOU
TI PHO TSEFTSAR OHE TTO SRY
ERGETOTH A B,UTOLSSEEC BAU
I
DCOULEL TL THE SRYTO OFOH J
NBR
IRNOW S
OU C GLDETENS IID J BNO'WNRO'S
AD.
RI WSS TEHITE LETNDRS A YOU
IOWKN,ET GHA T ITET GAM SEH WIT
LIUTN,OL BD N IEEO TW KNOT WHA
THK  LOOKELI TOPL PEOETH ON
U
AIDTSE INDLD WTOU BE GATREF I
I HAD TE SHEAMER POKN SOLOTGIN A
FTHBO OM THESEEC BA' I'MNG DOI
ANFF ETECHI TSOM CN RIPASO
DAN
ERFREDOUKIC D KASGLSOHWNE J
N
N.BROW
HE METOH JNWN BRON I THE0S 184
AN HO SET SORF OHAEW N WJOT HN
NBROW W T UPO ANDHE T KDINF O
H
HAGSIN TT JOWN OHBR THON PE
OC
SHMPCOLI HE ELLNTVEUAYET M
M RAABHAN NCLIOLDANEL WL,
AC TLYA'REHE'S A SIKIN
NTMOMEN I S THEHERYTO TTO S IRY
MYRY STOHE WN JREOHRO BES TWNRIN
O
TALDE FREOUCKRI D IASGLSONT
G INJOINIDE THRAN O HPEARRS
FEIGY,RR R AHTND FCKDERERI
DO.SSLAES
NO NIC BO,ASLYALHA WTREDECK
LADOUGS SSSAYS ' I' AMRRI WTE
TNO AIG FERHT BUT INIODD AITN
E
TKNEWHNT HAJO'RO BW'SD RAIIS H
IOMISSN WASON GL FNAAI BAUECSE
ICEDFRERGL DKOU HSASADEE BN
A
ESLAVEND A HNO KWHA TTLA SSVE
WE
NA GREONEI WGH TIRHEESHA CNC
OMOF CUTGIN OF OHI TSLI A,VEND A
OUEYTH WLI RLDEA T NZEOY'H'
REO
GVET RYD.OO
ANSOD CKDERERIASOU DGL
WS
OLESSUTHE TRE ON TJE SHEUB
F
ITABOL TNIOOHNHE JNWN BRO,UT B
HE F WASTHARERUT ORE THE TNHA
ABMHALNIN LCOND A SODE FRECKRI
SSUGDOLARI TES TOLO SWOH JN
BRN DNOWND AHE SRI TESO T
EESPD AAHBRAMLNIN LCONTP U U
HENGRI TIR FSTT PAR OTHF EAR WIU
ICEDFRERKASOU DGL ISN HIS
PEWSNEPARAM NED THEOU DASGL
L.URJONA
HEAT BSERBRGIN AAMAHCO LIN
LN
BFORNGEILOO S S
ISS I W AUT AARBOVE SLA YRYOU
OVEHA TREEC DLA O WAR
THN E
ESSLAVOU YE HAVOO DS, THIND A
E
US JTNK THISHA TTCO LIN'L'
SGO
OGIN SLO SW SOLO SW UILNT
FIHEYLL T EATNCMAIPNIO
MAOCPRLANDONTI AN THEE HAL FIN
A
KA,YS OCO LYINOU,LN YNO K
W,O
AL FUINLYOT RHTIGN OHI TS
CO LDINNG BLNRIGL DSOUAS IONTAN
WTHETEHI.OU HSE
ONHE CDESIRSIM H ADEON CFI INTN
IN LSTENTKIN IHEO T RONEPECTI
F
IS HON SECD IUGUR AALND SO
AN
D ADND AGLOUASINGA AS I SAY
ITOMFR L SARERYINNDTAPO IT,
EDNEEDE SOMF OT THAHI TSOU DASGL
HESHA TT LASD WOR INY M BKOO
BEEE HAL TUT AKSBOHE T
SICEICIFANF O BHOT JNOHWN BRO
DANAMBR AAHLNIN LCO A
SLUNCDESSN I ECEENT THA TYHE
OTREWE BSSNEH CE TY ARINIRHE
VIINDIAYALDU W TSTHO E OFUSCAE
EMONPACITIH, YEAEL WL,HA TNK
OUYO S BUC MHL.IL
O AWEREUT OE. TFIM
THATAS W A WULDEONRFAL T
K.I
NO KWUR OUD ANCIEEYEA RLL
APDIAECTEOUT I Y CANET G
'LLBI'OKS BO THE Z ALOEATND THE
EM
TOCIANPAROR FM THE GURTYETSBG
GERIHETA CTEENRT ASBET GTYGUR
UMMUSECOORSTE. AMND BLIL HAS
PR TNEIGDSEHEOO BS.LA PTE
AN SOELE PAS FRD OERHEMRO TRE
YOAND U CAN GETOU YR OWNY COP
SI BEDY
IL BL.
KTHAN. Y
N.AGAI
YANTHK.OU BNRFON WDE TAL
HEVELO TTUPP OOR
TYNI.
ILWHE PAPTOHOGRHSF OLI EARER
CTNFCOLIST ESXIIVHE T CILAR W
WA THE FSTIRO TE BSIXT EENLYVE
O
EDMECUNTGHHR T